uh no doubt another big disappointment
for all the mob in the media especially
fake news cnn
and that is the topic of tonight's
opening monologue beginning in 2015
the network's president we call him
affectionately mr potato head
that would be jeff zucker well he's
cashed in
on the left's anti-trump rage as a
result
facts so-called journalism took a back
seat as the anti-trump
radical conspiracy theories the hoax the
rumors
the smears dominated coverage 24 7.
now for over three years really over
five a network breathlessly breathlessly
telling their viewers
that the president of the united states
donald trump colluded with
with russia to steal the election well
hillary is the only one we know of that
had a dirty russian disinformation
dossier
they didn't spend much time on that in
june of 2017
three fake news cnn employees resigned
after reporting a fake story about a
russian
investment firm with ties to trump
officials also
june 2017 yup cnn again
forced to issue a correction because of
a fake story about comey's russia
investigation december 2017
cnn propagated another fake story about
trump's national security adviser
and russia and in december 2017
fake news cnn publishing a fake story
about donald
trump jr and wikileaks then in july
2018 more fake russian news this time
featuring the trump tower meeting in
july of 2019 at least one fake news cnn
host
was still accusing trump of russia
collusion
uh did they miss that story uh false
story
fake news and of course the terrible and
unethical reporting
didn't begin and end with russia may
2018 they also bash trump for putting
migrant kids in cages
based on a 2014 photo that would be when
obama
and president now then vice president
sippy cup
was in office in september 2018 the
network all but accused
brett kavanaugh of being guilty of every
charge made against him
in january of 2019 multiple so-called
journalists at cnn
slandering a 15 year old boy wearing a
maga hat
in washington d.c yeah cnn ultimately
settled
with nicholas sandman out of court i
don't know
i would bet it's tens of millions
clearly it is
hyper obsessive in their pursuit to
smear
all things donald trump 24 7. they got
it wrong
over and over and over again they've
never apologized they'd never corrected
the record and clearly
they're never going to change take a
look
source is now telling cnn that his
former fixer michael cohen claims
that then candidate trump despite his
many denials since
knew in advance about that june 2016
trump tower meeting here they see these
calls to the block number
and now there seems to be good evidence
that that was probably
president trump paul manafort the
president's former campaign chairman
paid secret visits multiple ones to
julian assange
at the ecuadorian embassy in london what
a great case officer
vladimir putin is he knows how to handle
an asset and that's what he's doing with
the president i just have to stop you
for one second first of all
the dossier has been corroborated by the
intelligence community
president says this plan will provide
little benefit for people
of wealth like himself is that true
in a word no it was pretty much every
second every minute every hour of every
24-hour
day and believe it or not most analysts
and hosts over there at fake news cnn
laughably refer to themselves as
unbiased journalists
something they're not that would include
yes
uh the stenographer for jeff zucker his
name would be humpty dumpty
of course humpty's not a journalist he's
a partisan hack
he does whatever jeff zucker tells him
to do and despite his title as a media
correspondent he's not one
humpty dumpty focuses almost all of his
efforts
i'm pretty much stalking this network
and yours truly which is somewhat
amusing
most of you probably don't know this but
he actually has a weekend show on fake
news
cnn that not that many people watch
little over 700 000
that would be a total disaster in
anybody else's world
and get this his new hate hannity hate
fox book
yeah nielsen numbers 1738 copies in its
first week
it was highly publicized and tonight by
the way
gotta give him credit he is number 5421
and that in terms of amazon's best
seller list and during his most
recent show humpty was just apoplectic
over my coverage of joe biden
and his protectors in the media mob had
a bit of a meltdown over it take a look
you have to hear the poisonous
propaganda that the gop's activist base
is listening to
you have to really hear it it's coming
more from sean hannity than from trump
right now
so that's what we did this week we
watched every episode of sean hannity's
show
and we color coded it as you can see we
focused on his language the insults and
phrases that he repeats every night
nasty little words don't get numb to
this abusive language
because it is through these insults it
is through these attacks
that hannity wields power this dark dire
language is fundamentally authoritarian
it's not opinion what hannity does you
know that's been the fox defense for
decades right
opinion shows we have opinion shows no
saying i don't know yes we should keep
the 2017 tax cuts in place
that's an opinion let's expand universal
pre-k that's an opinion
hannity is spouting something else
hannity is spouting poison
his definition of poison must mean that
i tell the truth that his book and his
show is a failure
anyway humpty not only claims to be the
great arbiter of truth
but now according to him he's also the
arbiter of what is
are acceptable opinions any sentiment
or adjective that offends him is poison
like telling the truth about him and
humpty well you've watched your own
channel's programming over the last five
years
you failed to report on all of the
failures of your network
one cnn analyst fantasizing about
punching
fifteen-year-old nicholas sandman in the
face you know for the crime of wearing a
maga hat
others referring to trump supporters as
klansmen
nazis and domestic terrorists sounds
like poison to me humpty
and that of course is only the tip of
the iceberg you decide
is this president trying to impersonate
hugo chavez
recep tayyip erdogan vladimir putin
trump is as destructive a person
in this century as hitler stalin and mao
were in the last century
he may be responsible for many more
million deaths than they were preserving
our heritage reclaiming our heritage
that sounds a lot like a certain leader
that killed members of my family and
about six million other
uh jews in the 1940s what do you call
someone who says
clearly racist things this morning the
answer is
mr president trump is a demagogue he is
a hate monger
and he is really bringing fascism to
america he's just
so insulting in so many ways and such a
crybaby it's just
disgusting he's almost leaving town like
a
an autocrat ousted from power
heading off into exile hitler
of stalin and mao humpty did you catch
any of that
were you too busy watching us over here
at fox ultimately humpty dumpty is
projecting he's lashing out
he's upset that he's been mocked and
humiliated a lot as
of late his re-release book with 13 new
chapters 30 to them
sold 1738 copies in its first week
now over 5 000 on amazon best seller
list despite a massive
nationwide pr campaign as news uh
well somebody else that works in his
family i'll be kind tonight
according to new york magazine now being
accused of
workplace bullying and cnn's fake news
ratings have plummeted a whopping 75
percent
things are not going well for him or
anybody at fake news cnn but mark my
words
pro stalker humpty well he'll never
police
uh my record of my opinions
or do his the way he does mine trust me
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else